[Music]
what's up
my fellow stupid last week we watched
six straight men versus one
secretly gay men and oh boy it was a
trick
are you gay no okay this is that was
hard
it doesn't work this time we're doing
the opposite six gay men versus one
secretly straight man that's even weird
to say that's funny
okay who's straight who's straight i'll
find you
when did everybody know that they were
gay literally my birth literally i had
oh my god it's black james charles holy
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] dude can i say that i
think i can say that yeah alright it is
it is it is fact
all right i think he's in the clear
we're feeling like kindergarten i
promise oh my god
yes i would say he's definitely gay as
well
all right we got four left let's go
if black james charles isn't gay i'll be
very confused
we brought together seven gay men i'm
gay i'm gay
i'm gay i'm gay i'm gay i'm gay i am gay
yeah i believe you i definitely believe
you all right just
watching all of them say honestly now
because it changes but just from looking
i know that's the point is that you
can't tell by looking at someone
what their orientation is except if
you're looking at blackjack
charles i'm gay i'm gay i'm gay
i think he's not the gay one look he
can't even say with a straight face
okay i'm gay i'm gay i'm gay
i'm gay i swear i'm gay i'm so gay
i just thought about this yeah gay
people can't be simps
at least guy gays that's not fair the
[ __ ] dude
if anyone calls someone gay sim you can
just be like
oh at least i'm not a sim that came out
weird you know what i mean that's like
the new thing for kids isn't it
haha you're a gay yeah well i'm not a
sim if the liar survives
he or she wins the entire prize
epic here we go i love these they're so
fun
i came out when i was 18 17.
[Music]
i know the point is that you can't judge
by their
okay my mom actually asked me when i
tried to tell her she basically took the
reins and she's like are you gay i'm
like
i was a little bit later so i kind of
hit it for a long time i was like 23.
it was like an anxiety round because
it's so short you can't really say
anything
so i was like let me say something so
then i'm not the one that doesn't say
anything before the round is over
i came out to my sisters when i was 17
and then i came out tomorrow when i was
21 because she found a cochrane in my
room
she found a what a [ __ ] running in his
room is that a metaphor
is that a gay metaphor or something she
was like what is this and i was like
oh everyone think it's him six percent
thought him
that he's insane he's the gay i mean
they're not gay
bro you cannot wear those shorts and not
be gay i don't believe that
there's no way what kind of man wears
shorts and
isn't gay straight
game my dude i don't make the rules i
don't make the rules don't shoot the
messenger
i think he's the knockout he's like let
me just see
stop me
i can't get over blackjack shots i
yeah i think he's a kerbal they always
do this
easy all right easy easy curveball i
would never fall for that
cringe honestly cringe that they felt
for that he's so
obviously plus he's like he's got the
gay posture
look one two three oh maybe that's the
thing one two three four
maybe that's the gay posture to have it
behind
it's not me sometimes people tell me i'm
not i don't like
necessarily look gay or quote unquote
what people might assume
looks gay just like the long hair and
maybe the clothes just like very i
thought long hair was super gay sorry
dave but i honestly what
bland
oh i'm sorry are we straight people too
flavorless for you gay
unbelievable no judgment
okay i have a question okay okay let's
do a hybrid
okay let's do a hypothetical real quick
if we were all on a baseball team
would you consider yourself bruh if if
black james charles isn't gay i'll
believe anything
anything can be real i i believe in
ghosts now
a pitcher a catcher i'm a catcher
pitcher
okay what does yeah we we we know
black james charles we know you don't
have to say it like that you don't have
to say it
i'll do both yeah pitch and catch i want
to say yeah more of a catcher
okay see they can pick what they want to
do it's gotta be
so much more fun being gay it's not when
did everybody know that they were gay
and what age the birth literally my
birth literally i had a boyfriend like
kindergarten i
probably i believe you might do wait who
is this
oh he kind of flew under the radar then
he you could be
you could be there no oh my god yes
literally his name is christopher and we
kissed on the slide in like kindergarten
and i was like i'm gay
mine was really suppressed during high
school um
if no one knows i'm trans so i have two
coming out stories so that's very
difficult to come out to your parents
multiple times well yeah technically
that's a weird story to lie about
that's very specific all right i believe
you come out three times
one i thought i was a lesbian because i
was born a woman so i thought
okay that's the thing and then after
that i was like no
i'm trans so i had to come out again
after that and then
i was like yeah i'm gay too many times i
mean he had three times where he came
out which i get you can come
in you can go out you can come and go
out but i'm just like i don't know
that's way too many times
how do you just make that up he doesn't
believe
it was just so repressed because my dad
was super homophobic
and you know which happened a lot in the
black community so
it was one of those things where yes
super heavily protected and guarded
and then it just kind of came to a point
in my life where like i realized like
this is my life i need to
you know do something for myself and not
live in that fear
so of course i ran away to san francisco
and and that kind of helped me like
accept it more
damn you forget about that i think the
the
the thing with coming out as gay it's
like uh a lot of people and i think my
approach a few years ago as well was
like oh it shouldn't matter
just uh it shouldn't be a big thing who
cares and i i still want to believe that
but at the same time there's clearly so
much homophobia
you see it everywhere online since
you're not surrounded by it you kind of
forget that it
it does exist so it's important to
remember and not just brush away
i don't know i don't know i was bullied
in high school for being gay
well i suppressed mine so yeah i know i
was dodging that bullying i'm not gonna
lie
i was getting bullied it'd be kind of
weird to come in here and like make up a
bunch of stories about how
suppressed you were growing up and then
be like actually i'm straight like
that'd be [ __ ] weird i mean i wasn't
saying like i was gay but they're like
you sound like a girl you're gay and i
would be like
i'd like rumors go around about me when
i was like denying it so i was like
super pissed
and now like i don't care has anyone had
sex with a girl
you haven't done i'm allergic i was very
drunk
i'm allergic to this very drunk pulled
out i fell in the vagina
it happens we've all been there my dude
no problem
i think this is actually disgusting i
went back in the house disgusting
that's the least anti-simp sentence i've
ever heard i
accidentally had sex with a woman it was
disgusting
that my dude there's a goddamn chant
right there
[Music]
maybe they did get it right the first
time and i thought maybe he was kind of
using that to kind of like trick us all
into thinking he was like a beyonce fan
so i was just like let me get him out
damn good luck guys it wasn't me
okay so what's everybody's favorite part
about our community
they're more accepting yeah yeah and
super open it's nice to have a community
of people that are
they've been through the same thing
you've been through who is
in a relationship not i i don't know
what that is
so x when was your last acts
mine was about two or three years ago
and i broke up with him because he was
still in the closet and i'm like
just out there like i don't have time
for that
and um dating someone that doesn't want
to
admit their sexuality publicly yeah
that's a weird thing
was like i helped him come out so like
when he told me about that i started to
cry
i was in my car i was like i think for
sure the straight man has been voted out
uh i don't think i think all of these
are gay who does everybody listen to
i'm more of an r b oh it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter who you listen to it
doesn't matter your word you're tasting
music doesn't define if you're gay or
not
so it doesn't matter i can't believe
black james charles even asked this
it's not even a question yeah yeah like
gay artists so what
all right that's the gate i've ever seen
you're cl you're
clear you're okay my dude okay
uh yeah i think he's gay yeah you're gay
he wasn't giving me enough a part of me
was thinking well
he might just be just a well-dressed
person
[Music]
was bellathorne once said ttylex away oh
my
god my dude just quoted bella thorne if
that ain't gay that [ __ ] gay
you gay as hell yeah what the who you
giggers hell my dude
what the [ __ ] ttl
as xox i thought oh oh i kind of hope
i kind of hope he is straight because
that would make it like that's a good
shot
and then there were four and that's the
final four
come on end it you surely have them out
i feel that you've eliminated them all
yes yes
please raise your hand
oh just me yes
all right so you guys want to keep going
yeah
i'm around all right i see a tattoo of a
lady on your arm
yes what inspired her i've dealt with
depression and self-harm and stuff
oh you have a lady on your arm what are
you [ __ ] straight
[Laughter]
are you straight dude stuff you got a
victory in your arm straight why not get
a man
i feel like you're like yeah what did
y'all do throughout high school
oh good like sports i did performing
arts
people didn't know right because i did
musical theater i did choir i did dance
i did a little bit i liked choir i like
theater
i like uh stop
can gay people stop stop generalizing
gay people i'm just kidding
football like a little bit i know yeah
i always attempted every year to like
play football
and then it always stopped when it came
time to actually play football
you know you remember the last episode
where the guys are like what do you
think when you saw penis
[Laughter]
i'm surprised no one's asked hey what do
you think vagina what do you think
huh what what words comes to mind when i
say this
boobs what words comes to mind hey look
at my eyes
are you gay
[Music]
are you serious no way
i have better gaydar than gay people
okay yeah please i didn't wanna
have that last round i kind of figured
we were all gay but
being selfish i just wanted it to be two
of us
okay no they stop you're done
what the [ __ ] this is becoming like a
gay competition who's most gay in here
dude
who's in the closet so where is he now
did you guys get back together after he
came out
no no because when i i also fell out of
love with him so i was like
i can't i can't i tried to get my flesh
and i was with him for a while and i was
like why the [ __ ] i'm doing this like
i'm sorry i don't like you anymore once
we started that round and
i think i went and gave him a question
like right away and he answered
it and i didn't feel he was lying so i
was like oh crap
that's the only question i had for him i
feel like we're all gay
yeah so why did you continue to play
[Music]
oh god now it's going to draw why did
you continue
you're so sneaky each one of you guys
gets 20 seconds what's the point
this is so lame okay um i'm gay um
i'll be sucking dick um straight person
do this
he's gay holy sh tens across the board
now i've seen that's the game's five
seconds of my life
because i i mean it took a while to come
to grips with it but
you know after coming to grips too bro
you gotta out game dude that's not doing
it seeing and
kind of showing that we come in
different colors and different styles
and different
you know everything so there's no one
right way to be gay just like there's no
right way to be straight you know
especially where you're going out
representation of just the whole
spectrum of everyone's show yeah this is
a great speech and i'll be
well connected we're all together you're
not getting there's someone
you know it's the same situation i was
in it's nice to be able to see that
and be able to be like okay so there is
a way you can still be yourself
and still not feel secluded
i am gay literally and
what straight man do you know could be
his face like this
oh here he comes here comes
[Music]
what are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] kid oh you [ __ ] camera dude
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
what why why why
did you not see the split dude guess
they teamed up huh
yeah yeah i was still hoping black james
charles was was uh straight
look at us yeah good job guys you really
have done your stuff
all right all right all right for real
this is one of these two
we didn't really get to hear him speak a
lot it could be him as well but i think
actually one of these three if i had to
guess let's say this guy
[Music]
how can you lie about coming out three
times that's insane you're insane
you came out too many times i was like
one of those times as you went back damn
and he knew that
that's so gay that he knew that yes that
means i'm not gay
[Music]
what does that mean coming out too many
times is that i don't
i don't i don't we're talking for too
much
i'm like
[Music]
well it was risky coming out to the
group here
so he came there and pretended to be
trends
that's weird is that one weird
transgender because a lot of
people invalidate just trans people in
general in the first place
a lot of people still care well that's a
fair thing i don't know i don't know
i do get it within the gay community my
gaydar and straight are very
horrible they're horrible i think it was
important to do this to kind of show
people that
there's you know spectrum of human
beings and
even if you identify with one group
that's not all who you are
yeah i agree with that please do they're
all moles
but they think they are the only one
yes jubilee please listen to your
audience
gay community we aren't only stereotyped
we are people too in this video
we throw him out because he didn't look
gay enough seriously how they
vote out adrian after that high kick
death
[Laughter]
wow another great episode sub to you
belay
sub to me thank you for watching smash
like if you want more videos
simp merch is out right now squirrels in
my pants of course nothing else
and see you guys in tomorrow's video
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]